Hello Freak pitches.
Well,
and that's something that I think that
we've historically had this really weird
approach to medicine,
which I think is kind of a secondary
effect of thinking scientifically.
And,
um,
obviously I,
my background is in neuroscience.
I worked as a scientist for many years
and I am very much a scientific thinker
and I'm all about the scientific method.
But I think that we sometimes are
at fault when we're a little bit too
reductionistic and our views.
And so if you look at the
history of modern medicine,
of signing a evidence based medicine,
what ends up happening is that we look
at a problem and we try to fix the
problem and we look at it as if you can
somehow cut that piece of the person's
physiology completely out of them,
solve it,
and then put it right back in.
And it doesn't have any effect
on anything else in their bodies.
I mean,
you look at medication,
right?
Um,
any,
any form of pharmaceutical,
they all have side effects.
If you think about what a side effect is,
it,
it comes down to how medication works.
Medicine is a molecule.
It's some sort of molecule that fits
in a receptors somewhere in your body.
And the idea is that you want
it to have really high efficacy.
So let's say that I'm somebody
who has a problem with um,
blood pressure for example,
or actually let's just jump
into depression because
I've been talking about this
a lot lately around um,
Robin Williams.
I had Paul Gil Martin on my podcast
just last week to talk about that.
He hosts the mental illness happy hour
podcast and has really great insights
into,
um,
mental illness.
And I of course publicly have dealt
with depression most of my life.
I take medication every day.
I go to therapy every week.
I'm very open about it.
For a lot of people,
they would look at you,
especially people that don't
have any issues with depression,
obviously very intelligent,
beautiful young.
Why would you be depressed,
tripping over themselves,
trying to date you,
you,
you're obviously very successful
in pursuing intellectual pursuits.
Why would you be depressed?
Exactly.
Why we're getting,
a lot of people don't understand the
differences between depression and sadness
and they don't understand that
depression is a biological illness.
They don't think of it and they also
don't think of it in terms of like people
look at it in terms of like,
well,
you've got all these sums,
these numbers.
Look,
there's all stack on that.
Almost Ken can make it
worse for certain people.
I mean,
you look at somebody like Robin Williams,
he had so much going for him,
right?
He was famous,
he was loved.
He had all this money.
How could he be depressed?
He didn't have the problems that you are.
I have and you know what?
Then you have this extra layer of guilt.
You have this extra layer of shame,
this extra layer of why the
fuck am I still depressed?
No matter how much success I get,
no matter how much money I make,
no matter how much people write me
letters and say that they love me and
whatever,
I can't seem to to beat
this feeling inside of me,
this constellation of symptoms
because it's not coming from that.
It's coming from your brain and is it,
I mean,
I don't suffer from depression,
but I have had many friends who do and um,
I have always wondered what it's because
it seems to be that when you go to a
doctor and they start treating it,
whether they treat it with medication
or they try to adjust your diet and in
prescribed exercise first,
that there's no like one simple fix and
everybody's completely different and
people get,
people get upset about that because I
think it goes back to to kind of what I
was talking about before,
which is a meandering way to,
okay,
so again,
to go back to this idea of a drug,
you take a drug,
let's say I take an antidepressant.
My antidepressant specifically is a
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor,
an Ssri that's called [inaudible].
That's the off brand.
I think it's Alexa,
um,
is the brand name.
I take that it binds to my serotonin
receptors in my brain and it allows me to
dump more serotonin into the synapse
that the gap between two brain cells so
that I always have more available.
It basically tells my brain
that I need more serotonin.
So I make more serotonin
available to myself.
It's a,
it's a re uptake inhibitor.
And so,
um,
or sorry,
it keeps more serotonin in,
in the gap instead of sucking
it back into the cell.
So I always have more available
to me now it's a molecule,
it's got a shape just
like anything out there.
It has geometry,
so it binds to this specific receptor
in the brain because it got a similar
shape to that.
There are other things in your
body that are similarly shaped.
And so what ends up happening
is when you take a drug,
the specificity of the drug is only
based on whether or not the key fits in a
locked somewhere in your body.
But let's say that you
had hundreds of thousands,
millions of locks available to you and
one key and you started going through,
you'd be able to stick
that in a bunch of locks.
Some of them,
it might even turn,
but it would,
it would fit in the lock of
multiple locks hanging on that wall.
So what ends up happening
is I take this drug,
it binds in my brain.
It does what it's supposed
to do in my brain,
but it also may be does other shit like
makes me really fucking tired or it
makes it so I don't want
to have sex as often.
It's a side effect.
And the reason that you have a side
effect is because there's other parts of
your body that the drug binds to.
It's the same thing with medicine.
Like you were saying,
you operate on somebody whose heart,
the heart is connected to other things.
It's it,
it's the source of blood
flow throughout your body.
It is connected to hormone levels.
There's all sorts of things that can
happen when you put somebody on her under
anesthesia,
when you cut them open,
when you uh,
you know,
you,
you cause an immune response
and inflammatory response there,
your body is a holistic thing.
And so when you start
jacking with certain things,
other things are going to happen.
That doesn't mean you should throw
the baby out with the bath water.
But medicine is a risk
benefit analysis always.
How do they find the,
it seems to me that they find the right
medication by experimentation that they
try it.
And is that just because it's,
cause we don't have any tests.
I can't,
you can't go up as a doctor.
You can't come to me,
stick a needle in my spinal cord,
take out my cerebral spinal fluid and
measure how much their tone in I have in
it.
I wish you could.
I wish I could take some sort
of a blood test or I could,
you know,
p and a cop and then you could analyze
that p and say you're low on Saratonin.
You need an Ssri.
That would be what works for you.
Because other people's depression
comes from problems with dopamine,
comes from problems with norepinephrine
or some combination thereof.
But there's no test for it.
It fucking sucks.
There's no test for it.
And so what ends up happening is
you have to play a musical chairs.
You try a drug,
maybe it does.
The first drug I tried for aunt,
uh,
when I decided to finally
go on antidepressants,
fucked me up so bad.
I took an s,
n,
d r I,
a selective serotonin norepinephrine,
dopamine reuptake inhibitor.
I was so fucking depressed,
I couldn't function and we decided
let's throw the book at it.
Let's take the drug of all drugs,
the monster drug that does everything
and I couldn't sleep for a week.
I felt like I was on straight up crank,
like on crystal lot done.
I quit smoking.
No,
seriously,
I quit smoking.
It was awesome.
That's when I quit smoking.
That's an important point.
Terrible for your body.
Horrible.
Did you do anything to try to naturally
stimulate your body to produce more
serotonin?
Did you try a lot of exercise?
Did you adjust your diet
but you didn't quit smoking?
I did.
I mean ultimately got on the
drugs only on the drug for a week.
So as soon as I got off the drug again,
I immediately wanted to smoke again.
But at that point I'd pushed
through it and I said,
you know,
I'm,
I'm at my lowest.
I was at my lowest
point I've ever been at.
So I was like,
fuck it can't get any worse.
And I did.
I quit smoking.
The thing about depression that is
fascinating to me is that there are some
correlations between how do are you happy
with what you choose to do with your
day.
I had a friend who was,
he was on like some serious
and they changed his life.
They got him,
he,
he quit his business,
he quit his job,
brother started his own business,
got involved in relationship,
and then once he got
to a really good place,
he slowly weaned himself off the
antidepressants and now he's great.
Yeah,
and that happens to a lot of people
and so I think that there's different,
what we have to understand too is of
course all psychiatric disorders or
spectrum disorders,
right?
There's really extreme examples
and there's barely any examples.
And if anybody who's ever taken
a psych course or who studied,
you know,
if you were a psych major in college,
you know that as you've
studied the DSM four,
which is like,
it's called the diagnostic and statistical
manual that they use in psychiatry
and psychology.
It's basically the big Bible of all
the things you can be diagnosed with.
The more you study it,
the more you're like,
I have that.
Oh,
I totally fucking have that.
And you realize everybody has,
everybody can convince
themselves that they have these,
it's like web MD,
you know what I mean?
So it's only once it is sufficient,
Lee,
detrimental to your life that
it affects your relationships,
it affects your ability to work,
it affects your health,
whatever the case may be.
And usually within the DSM,
there maybe like eight things and it's
like you have to have five out of these
eight things.
And so anybody can read it and go,
Oh,
I felt depression before.
But what they don't realize is there
is a difference between depression and
sadness.
There's also a difference
between parody depression.
So depression that lasts years,
decades,
and the type of depression that people
get that's directly linked to life
events.
And that's your dog dies,
you look well,
a big one,
you lose your freaking job.
Like we've seen so many
documentaries lately about this.
As the economy took a downturn,
people lose their job and then they
end up committing suicide because they
can't.
It's like this cascade of awfulness.
That's a really common one.
Um,
you know,
family member dies,
you have a stillborn or you have an
abortion or you how you have a baby,
a healthy baby.
Postpartum depression is incredibly
common and in that case that's much more
common that people can take meds,
they can do all these things and once
they get back to where they were before
that horrible life event,
they're okay to get off off the meds.
Some people are able to get their
depression managed without medication
perfectly well.
Some people aren't.
Is the different reactions of different
people have two different medication?
Is it because their depression has
a different source or is it just a
biodiversity?
I think it's more of a biodiversity
thing than a source thing.
I mean as sources,
hard to say.
So depression is both
when you think about it.
Well,
brain and mind are the same thing.
Most modern neuroscientists say that
brain and mind are two sides of the same
coin.
That mind is just an
emergent property of brain.
Nobody's a dualist anymore.
They don't think that you
can like heal the mind.
And it has no effect on the brain
because it's the same fucking thing.
So there are,
you know,
some people's depression comes from the
fact that their dopamine levels are,
are not healthy or they're norepinephrine
levels are not healthy or whatever the
fuck.
But I think the common view of depression
now is that there's some sort of
biological difference in your brain and
oftentimes that's either caused or it
develops out of childhood or early
life experiences where you know,
you have some sort of trauma
or you have some sort of um,
development.
You have some sort of,
you know,
interaction with family,
whatever the case may be.
And it doesn't have to be,
you know,
you were molested as a child.
It can literally just
be like you didn't feel,
um,
loved or whatever the case may be.
And you've got this brain
difference combined with
this emotional experience and
what ends up happening.
Because when you're very young,
you're brain is very plastic.
So when you're very young,
you're learning skills that are going
to last you the rest of your life and
you're actually building
your brain architecture,
certain neurons connecting
and disconnecting and
reconnecting and pruning out
the tree.
The beautiful tree that is all of the
cells in your brain is getting pruned when
you're young and if you're depressed
when you're young and you're experiencing
those kinds of things when you're young,
you're going to prune a tree that's
prone to depression as you age because
you're going to keep reinforcing
those neuronal connections.
That's why therapy is so important.
Meds in and of themselves are never
going to get you in a place where your
depression has really well managed.
It's going to get you in a place where
therapy is going to be working better for
you.
Meds are going to be an immediate and
necessary interventional strategy so that
you're not crying or you're not
trying to kill yourself or you're not.
Whatever your symptoms of so you can
actually fucking get out of bed to work on
yourself.
That's what meds are there for me.
It.
Meds keep me from staying in bed all day.
That's a variable though.
Finding the right counselor has
got to be incredibly difficult.
It's tough.
It's like I always liken it to the
women who are listening to the podcast.
I liken it unto when you were first
deciding to go on birth control,
a lot of women will go um,
to their gynecologist when they're 15,
16,
17 and say,
I want to go on birth control
and they'll give them Ortho,
try cycling or whatever,
the pill,
the regular old pill,
and they'll be fine.
A lot of women will take the pill the
first time and it'll make them really
sick.
Like every time they take the pill,
it makes them want to throw up or it
gives them cramps or something's weird
about it.
It affects us and they go,
oh,
of this drug doesn't work for me and go,
Oh fuck,
okay,
let's try one with lower levels of
estrogen or progesterone or let's try the
ring or the Depo Provera shot,
or maybe you need an Iud.
I was like that.
It took me multiple times
to find the right drug.
And I think it's the
same thing with therapy.
I think it's the same thing
with psychiatric medicines.
It's not,
we're not monolithic,
so the same combination isn't
gonna work for everybody.
And the truth is if that makes you afraid
of modern medicine or if it makes you
think that psychiatry is
Wu or something like that,
it's the same thing as
cancer in many ways,
there's so many parallels.
Cancer's not one disease.
It's a spectrum of diseases.
If I got diagnosed with breast cancer
and you got diagnosed with breast cancer
and we both went in with
our diagnosis the same day,
our oncologist would give us different
treatments because we would have
different genetic markers.
We would respond differently to
different types of chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy,
it means chemical therapy.
It's a really big umbrella term for all
the different kinds of cancer treatments
that are available.
Maybe you would get more radiation,
maybe I would need surgery,
but your metastasis would make it so
that surgery wasn't a viable option.
It's,
it's a spectrum.
Disease and psychiatric
illness or the same way.
The variable though of the
counselor has to be kind of weird.
It is weird.
It's a weird find someone that you can
confide in whole heartedly and it takes
time a really long time
finding the correct sex.
Right.
Whether or not as some men do
better with women counselors.
I have a male counselor,
um,
like I would never,
it's funny,
I have a male therapist but I have a
female gynecologists like I would never in
a million let a dude like puts speculums
and me and like dig around in my
cervix.
But I'm totally comfortable
with a male therapist.
When did the depression started?
When I was child.
So you were dealing
with it your whole life?
My whole life.
Oh completely.
Some of those years,
like when I was dating bill
or when I would be moving,
those were some of the worst years because
it was so stressful cause he didn't
have friends and because I was
unmedical I was unmedicated then.
Yeah.
I didn't start taking medication
until about three years ago.
Really got 27.
Did you try other methods you try?
I didn't try.
I tried some things and I,
I've been in therapy my whole life.
My parents first put me in therapy when
they first started to decide that they
were thinking about getting a
divorce and I was a young man.
I was maybe six or seven.
So from the time I remember,
I've understood the therapeutic process
and they always really promoted that in
me.
So then even after the divorce
and remarriage is and all of that,
I started doing the,
the therapy thing on my own.
Then when I went to college
and I was very much on my own,
I went to college when
I was 16 by the way,
and lived on my own at
60 I was fucking weird.
K Yeah,
so I was a little,
I'm an adult,
but I wasn't.
I did that.
I went to therapy.
I did all those things by myself,
but I always had this mental block.
I always had this like,
oh,
I don't need meds.
Meds means you're really crazy.
Meds means you really don't have control.
And not until I kind of hit
a very bad rock bottom a few,
maybe three years ago did I finally say,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I've,
I think I actually have to do this.
I think it would be good for me.
And then it was the same experience that
I've heard over and over and over from
people where finally they get on the
meds that are right for them and they
calibrate to their dosage
and maybe they've been on
it for about two months and
they just have this epiphany of like,
why the fuck did I wait so long?
I could have felt like this my whole life.
What the fuck was I thinking?
Because you're so societaly.
We're so resistant to looking at mental
illness the same way we look at physical
illness.
We're so,
it's so easy.
Paul Gil Martin just made this point
when he was on my podcast last week.
If you went up to somebody with diabetes
type one diabetes and you were like,
what the fuck dude?
Why don't you just think more positively
so that your pancreas makes insulin?
Like what's wrong with you?
Why can't you just make more insulin?
It's like they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
It's the same thing with depression.
People put the onus on you.
Like they,
they look at it like
it's a disease of will,
but it's not.
It's a,
it's a biological illness and that's
just very hard for people to understand.
And so what you end up doing is carrying
around a lot of guilt and shame and a
lot of feelings.
Like,
I'm not good enough.
I can't will myself out of this
if I just think more positively.
It's not about that.
And I did that for years.
Years.
You just deal with it.
And I destroyed,
oh,
so many relationships.
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine being
trapped in that scenario,
but I'm also very sensitive to the
variables that different people
go through with their bodies.
I have hypothyroidism,
I have to take thyroid medication.
It runs in my family.
My mother has it grown.
Has it too.
Yeah.
And uh,
I,
I know I should get headaches,
these weird headaches at the
end of the day where I was like,
ah,
so fuck.
Like I could fall asleep
and it wasn't like,
it wasn't like I was like,
now I,
I get tired,
I go to sleep.
But it was like I could fall asleep just
watching TV and be out for like eight
hours.
Like it didn't make any sense.
It was like a weird tired,
like I was in pain.
So,
uh,
and I get these weird headaches.
And then once I finally got on medication,
it was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
right.
You're like,
oh,
this is,
this is what other people feel like,
right?
Like I thought I was normal
because that's another thing.
There's such a stigma in this country,
not just about mental illness,
but about any sort of illness where
people can't openly freely talk about it.
So you end up living in this weird
bubble where you don't really,
like,
I know people that have mental illness
that didn't even realize they had mental
illness until they finally
had a conversation with a
doctor about it and they
were like,
oh,
this isn't normal.
Like not everybody doesn't hear
voices or everybody does it.
It's like,
yeah,
because you're so afraid to
talk to somebody about it.
So that's,
I mean that's a really
important part of this.
I think it's just getting past the stigma.
That's why when something
like this with Robin Williams,
which is so fucking depressing happens,
a lot of people rally
around it and they say,
hey,
maybe we can use this as a
teaching moment because this guy,
no matter how good his life was,
he had this thing that he ultimately
couldn't kick and it wasn't his fault.
It just is that way sometimes and hey,
maybe you have it too.
I think in some ways it's good when high
functioning people come out and talk
about their illnesses because then people
who are actually experiencing things
like loss of employment,
loss of a loved one,
whatever,
or who have had a bad go of it for
other reasons or like even you,
like you had said before,
like even you,
but you're pretty or,
but you're successful and you're whatever.
Well,
if you could have that,
then of course,
it's not weird that I have,
you know,
it's like it's a good thing for people
to be able to see that they're not alone
like that.
Yeah.